- [Voiceover] Let f of t equal either
the 2t minus 2t squared,
and h of t equal four minus 5t squared.
The graphs of y equals f of t,
and y equals h of t, are shown below.
So y equals f of t is here in green,
so this is really y is equal to
e to the 2t minus 2t squared.
We see f of t right over there.
And y is equal to h of
t is shown in yellow.
All right.
Now below that, they say,
"Which of the following
"appear to be solutions of
e to the 2t minus 2t squared
"equals four minus 5t squared?
"Select all that apply."
And I encourage you to pause the video
and try to think about it.
Now the key here is to realize
that either the 2t minus 2t squared,
that was f of t.
And four minus 5t squared is h of t.
So another way of thinking about it,
select all of the Ts for which f of t
is equal to h of t.
So all of the Ts where f
of t is equal to h of t,
well that's going to happen
at the points of intersection.
So for example, at t1,
we see at this point right here, t1 y1.
So this tells us f of t1
is equal to h of t1,
which is equal to y1.
So f of t is going to be equal to h of t
at t is equal to t1.
We see that there because
it's a point of intersection.
Now let's keep on going.
Well they have another
point of intersection
right over here at t4, t4 y4.
If you took f of t4,
you're going to get y4.
Or if you take h of t4,
So f of t4 is equal to h of t4.
f of t4 is equal to h of t4.
So if you took e to the two times t4
minus two t4 squared,
and all the way, that's going to equal to
four minus five times t4 squared.
Since f of t and h of t equal each other,
when t is equal to t4,
these two things are
going to equal each other,
when t is equal to t4.
And those are the only ones
that are at a point of intersection.
And so I think we are done.
I can check my answer,
and I got it right.